welcome to podcast ville the Church of
what's happened now is brought to you by
zip recruiter in need of great talent
for your business but short on time you
don't have to get lost and they you
stack of resumes to find your perfect
hire you just need the right tools with
zip recruiter you can post your job to
over 100 of the web's leading job boards
with just one click so you can rest easy
knowing your job is being seen by the
right candidates find out today why zip
recruiter has been used by grown
businesses of all sizes and industries
to find the most qualified job
candidates with immediate results and
right now the church to what's happened
now can post jobs on zip recruiter for
free that's right Uncle Joe is coming
through again free just go to zip
recruiter calm slash church again that's
zip recruiter doctrines last Church one
more time to try for free go to zip
recruiter com slash Church number two
but days are back let me explain a
situation that's gonna happen in two
weeks your family's only come over you
ask any turkey they can eat by pumpkin
pies salads everything's happy but if
you invite ten people four people going
on your bathroom and [ __ ] that
[ __ ] up then sit on your couch
with that rotten ass protruding leaking
Kruti underwears you know your
grandmother's ass stinks like a [ __ ]
mule so this year make sure your family
shits in your house they leave with a
clean ass get a tissue birthday for $69
well the risk-free
60-day trial for starters go - hello -
she calm and use the code church for 10%
off your order
hello - she's gonna change your life you
know what why cuz you [ __ ] gonna be
clean and when your relatives are coming
over there our souls could be clean so
you'll be one [ __ ] happy family of
clean [ __ ] [ __ ] all right take
that [ __ ] meal leave
well in your [ __ ] living room reading
this [ __ ] welcome to the Church
of what's happening now Josh wolf my man
Lisa yet herb is in the house before we
get this started if you came to the
shows in New York thank you very much if
you got hit a mat with a chair I'm sorry
things happen at the church for unions
that's like an Irish waiting for church
reunions somebody always leaves with a
bottle get hit in the head but listen we
had great times you guys a family thank
you very much for showing up but you
said you didn't even know I didn't even
know what's going on yeah it was like
Puerto Rico my [ __ ] them in this
phase there was chairs thrown and [ __ ]
but hey that makes for a good night you
like entertainment and stuff like that
it's memorable
it is very memorable what's up with you
mr. wolf what were you this weekend
Atlanta Georgia yeah man how was that I
love that club the punch line down there
good little punch me yeah do you like
that I've never been there I really like
it they love you Marcy loves you down
there
okay we were talking about shape but
that Club is just cool it's and it's in
Buckhead now and I love the Atlanta
crowds how far is it from the airport
man still be our 25 okay it's not the
local no no no no that one was that
they're not at that anymore they're in
like bucket it's like 25 minute was a
punch line what was line there was it
there was an improv for a little bit but
punch line was the one that you did the
punch line was the one you did but it
was way out there was way out there
right this one is just closer to
downtown yeah I didn't like that [ __ ]
long ride unless you were in the middle
of no - that's [ __ ]
cuz you couldn't get out of the hotel
and do and that you were in the middle
of [ __ ] nowhere I like like I'm
getting a little older I like the gigs
to be somewhere like it where I can get
out of the hotel and just like see
something just saw something walk don't
leave me to unit either Sam Riley I like
the Sun I think yeah when you're in your
hotel room too long like some mornings I
gonna have your breakfast
smoke a joint you go back to your room
you read you're right it's 11 o'clock
you like something's not right
yeah something's all right and you go
outside and you're like this is what I
need
the Sun you want to go somewhere when
they put you in those hotels of the
close to the industrial park those are
the worth the one constantly like a
couple years ago yeah like the one in
Austin but then I made him bring me back
the Doubletree but you know sometimes
you're in your hotel for too long this
weekend my the do not disturb was on the
door all weekend and I didn't really
leave the hotel room so at one point
housekeeping knocked and asked is
everything okay is everything okay
everything's okay everything you sure
Mike yeah fine they say do you need
anything I'm like no I'm good it's like
sometimes I just get stuck sometimes I
just get stuck in the hotel room
sometimes you know if you're not near
anything yeah I just get stuck and and I
just pulled the [ __ ] shades and I'm
there all weekend oh but lot of people
understand is you know I was talking
about the downfall at Houston we spoke
about the Houston comedies I was talking
to you about it and we were talking
about you know when you went to Houston
15-20 years ago it was such a party oh
yeah and it was a great party what was
that close there laughs yeah that was it
and it started Tuesday and you would
that throw something yeah I stayed til
Monday for the open mic because you
never missed the open mic that you know
and when you left there I realized that
a lot of those guys drank every night
uh-huh like they just went from headline
of the headline you know saying like
who's here next week David Tata will
back him on yeah you know they had those
type of lineup so when they came to
Houston when they came to light it see
the same comics and now we're not
drinking you know because you're in that
way you gotta get up late you gotta be
sharp people understand when you go on
the road you're a different animal you
have to be now there's two different
types of atoms there was what I was till
ten years ago and if I knew I was
leaving Wednesday night I would just
Norton Monday and Thursday because I was
like what's the users Oasis north one I
can't stop to attend to my wife walls
and in the on the road yeah it's
starting as soon as I get offstage and
stay in that hotel room did you snort
the entire time you are on the road
yeah did you from we there was never a
weekend that I didn't do coke or scored
in one way or another it got worse is it
but like towns like Houston Miami that
was just for me was a snort athan yeah
what you know it's like those guys that
sell t-shirts that's why I don't sell
t-shirts because I never want to come
back to you and you go how was your week
or its old lady yeah you didn't tell me
nothing about you Tommy you gonna tell
me if you bomb the third show you didn't
tell me the improvise you didn't tell me
that you had great crowd you didn't tell
me nothing you know it says it's the
same thing I didn't go there for the
economy I went there because I had three
coke dealers and I was about to make
1,600 bucks in two weeks did you book
cities that you knew you could get
cocaine absolutely how Paso Houston
Miami Buffalo anywhere I knew was right
there in the club like I don't have to
[ __ ] around and wait for Johnny help
yeah so like Kelly Moran no I he was
somewhere else he was in public well
maybe he wasn't loving in those places
you know wherever you are in Texas this
bloke so no matter what time you going
all you need is three hours and you bump
into a Mexican and with a 10-minute
Samuel come around the hill with bales
of blow but no that's the way it was
towards the end I'm not gonna lie the
entire I went out for the yard I went
out because I knew I was going to stay
somewhere where I wouldn't be bothered
one of the worst coach coke binges I
everyone I was Aronian in Vegas he had
nothing new and I paying how bad I was
but he had no idea no idea and it was I
was getting coke from the guy in Vegas
that was giving you an ain't bought for
90 bucks no no maybe like 110 but for
125 he gave you a come down kit actually
give you to vicodins to xanaxes and
something else something crazy like
nothing spectacular a real we learned
dealer this flour towel don't get me the
sanest give me the vicodins which is no
bueno
so we got another Thursday night and my
friends were in town from New Jersey
they were like a big time hotel and they
kept calling me gonna come over I didn't
see them the whole weekend sadly like
Joe didn't get until Friday I had a
whole night without Joe like they called
me said do you want the radio Friday
doesn't want to do it yeah I got a room
Thursday night yeah I'm on it and I
would go to Vegas call that guy and he
was so tight with the hotels that he was
walking it right to your room
you know most hotels don't let you go up
the elevator without the kid yeah yeah
yeah you know everybody greased
everybody's bought 10 minutes he know
where are you I'm at the hotel right
next door I'll be then tablet you like
oh good you know like a little bit left
you know say anything you gotta make the
call yeah that's not gonna last it's
3:30 I gotta go till 7:00 a.m. I mean
that that's a good drug dealer right
there oh he was a brilliant drug I
remember I forget who you were
complaining about who you were
complaining that they were a bad drug
dealer but I remember when we were it
made me laugh you were like this
[ __ ] is the worst do you hear
like he doesn't pick up the phone I'm
like dude he's a drug dealer you're like
they gotta have some etiquette it's why
you always got all your drug dealer
something yeah i'ma tell you 160 [ __ ] I
only brought 120 I'll call you tomorrow
at the forty don't pick up the phone you
old boy house oh he always got all your
attorney money he sends you a bill for
25 to 50 the lawyer opens oh that
[ __ ] man is like this mother for this
[ __ ] this my degrees under guess
why when the bill says 2500 and then he
calls you
now he asked to call you and ask you
what happened you still go over the case
with him and he can't charge you coz he
called you wait if they call you they
can't charge because he's calling me for
the money but by the way by the time I
try that you always if you have a
problem people I pick up the phone yeah
Oh money oh yeah they won't always pick
up the phone I had those drug dealers on
phone what be dialed that really listen
and I've heard you say a lot of things
that makes about as much sense as
anything I don't sell a book 180 ad I
love when they leave that hinge that
hook yeah that that's how I get you
how much 155 I'll give you 140 what
about the 15 I'll be back tomorrow
then tomorrow I come back for a gram at
60 so what do I owe you
75 don't come with 50 oh and now I owe
you 25
so I get you deeper in the hole without
you even knowing ah I installed my when
I was running those Street drug dealers
no compadre I always had to pay cash
there's nothing you can do that's cash
and carry but the other guys
I always owe them money I own a money to
actually threaten me is that right yeah
hey Joey the tab is too high yeah I'd
have the money but I refuse to give it
them because I my addiction was so
strong I never wanted him not to pick up
the phone I always told the next Dan
have that 700 400 to 700 tomorrow did I
call him to show up with two and forth
another 8-ball oh so now I got you back
in the [ __ ] 625 how many people would
you owe money to at one time three ah
what year what years were that was that
years from our mothers okay when I was
in New York
everything's cash and carry you know 40
oh yes if you go into Manhattan
when you get personal dealers people saw
the house their cash and then they're
there always you treat them good from
one you keep some point then you start
smacking them around [ __ ] crazy I
have to tell you the thing one of the
things that I like the most about the
legalize weed out here is that you don't
have to go to that dude's apartment and
get you and just sit on the couch and
pretend like you like them you know what
I mean
and pretend like you want to smoke a
joint with him or whatever or pet is dog
or whatever the [ __ ] you know that I I'm
really glad that that part cuz you been
knocking the door and he'd be on the
couch like come in come in if I can you
know I don't miss that I don't like
tonight I did stop at the weed store
it's the same [ __ ] on the partner really
get out of it I take my wallet out give
my [ __ ] license sometimes I don't
have cash I go to a Russian ATM machine
which means Trump got my [ __ ] license
number ATM number then I go on by the
way the same [ __ ] thing
they they they throw these hot girls at
you that don't know about weed and they
skill you what catch them I mean while
they weigh a buck ten and they listen to
whatever that boyfriend says so I'm in
the same predicament yeah by the way
when people tell you that their weed is
good
they have no idea I throw it away I tell
I try to help people out and yeah yeah
yeah yeah I ain't gonna do nothing tell
me there was a kid at the ice house for
three weeks
this is my test there was a kid the ice
house kept bugging me for three we say
man I grew this weed here it is talked
about it on the show now I smoked it at
night nothing happened
mmm-hmm the next one I got nice and
early nothing happened well I take a
[ __ ] in the more their first [ __ ] I'm
smoking at the same time cuz I got the
bathroom the door some [ __ ] and smuggle
at the same time if I call you at 7:30
in the morning
Moka pot restaurant a legit I'm sitting
there with the pipe smoking and then
when I finish I wipe my hands i watch
players I pick up the pipe again
and I go back to town how often when you
call me in the morning are you taking
[ __ ]
if I'm calling you in the morning
sometimes I'm sitting in my dad's but if
I go on the bathroom I use that's my
fault I smoke while I'm writing tweets
is [ __ ] yeah
people call him because I call he's
awake I'm awake man I gotta stop doing
what I'm doing for you yeah I'm on a
roll right now I'm listening to music
darling weed I'm not stopping to talk to
you dummy
my phone's on the charger anyway so now
when I go to the bathroom I return those
calls
well I'm sorry he talked to you when
he's taking a [ __ ] all this I don't tell
people I'm taking this [ __ ] I'm not that
rude I just take this [ __ ] talk to you
about business with oh my god I did a
podcast once on the phone and this kid
was Turner peed in the middle of it oh
yeah I never released it he did he took
a pee during the middle you can hear the
low peak he never released what swine
podcast huh
well that's Jay if it's really crazy
when you what are we talking about we're
on a good say yeah I know drug dealers
weed dealers yeah all that [ __ ] you I
like all the drive I miss calling a
drunk and it took me the longest to get
a license because I did not like the
whole process of it I missed the Friday
I miss forgetting you to a knowledge
check I really messed getting your $240
check and getting your check cashing it
going through the bank putting 100 in
the bank a 140 ain't going to that weed
dealers house and buying your little $35
bag of weed and putting it in the trunk
and driving home knowing that's illegal
and then you'd stop at a liquor store
you stop at the coke dealers house you
got something in your roll of paper it's
a complete sir I liked it because you
can still do all of that except replace
going to the weed dealers house with
walking into a store with lots of
options yeah I mean you did many options
though I like places that I wish I mean
I wish and I told some of the other that
but better weed now or before we came 20
years too
too early because I wish that I could
put a camera tap it and show people my
memories like I really wish like there
was a place I bought coca are you just
walked in and there was a dinner table
where was a card game it wasn't even a
deli table as a card table that's it an
account two couches in the living in
Hollywood no [ __ ] Hollywood NYC old
school where you'd walk in there'd be a
guy with a gun three guys with guns at
the door
Colombians or Dominicans and you sit in
the couch the other day and then you're
next you walk in the room there's two
bags of coke there's a little electronic
scale God puts a card on the table you
snort it takes the other batch you snort
that what do you want thirty five twenty
five and you get it he puts a little
foil gives it to you gives the cash to
some other guy on the way out and that's
it on the whole way they got three
people garden us just like that I used
to buy coke of places like that one of
the first places that well coke was was
137th in Amsterdam and there was a
Columbian disco
yeah daytime they fought chickens so I
always want at night now at night you'd
walk in there and there were people at
the door [ __ ] lit like this is 8283
with guns all right think I'd check out
an ID we'll have a gun and he would walk
you'd walk in and you'd say I'm here to
see Josh and right there they press a
buzzer and Josh his head would be DJ it
so Josh would be DJing ok you know 82
spinning the records must be the music
all these Spanish people don't speak
English you know and they charge them $7
a beer and then when the Spanish stuff
you'd walk into the DJ booth he closed
the door and before he closed the door
he'd stick his hand in the door you see
that if I opened the door the door has a
thing up on top they caved it out and
they'd hide the coconut are in the top
of the door under the door so he would
stick his hand out take the baggie out
and he had a scale in between the two
turntables it was crazy
this is 82 I was in hey I still remember
that the night that you know when they
do the scene II Awards most likely to
succeed huh like that night for example
my friend Sabatini knows father had run
liquor store so our plan was to go into
the city cop get weed coke and on the
way back robbed the liquor store he had
the keys in the alarm codes I will never
ever forget that night so think about it
the night that you're giving away award
yeah me this kid ferny and this kid
stinky went into the city while the
awards were on and we picked up four
eight-balls ludes you know by the time
we got for the awards ceremony it was
over high school but the kids that I
went with were like my friends come on
the way you won - kid that drove won
best body and he was wooden made getting
on in the city but you would walk to the
back through people be dancing and you'd
walk through the dance floor
they'd open the DJ thing for you and
he'd get the coke from the door and he'd
sell you whatever you want a couple heat
balls and [ __ ] grams of coke that was it
at that time that's all I was buying
that was my analysis or nothing but
that's like a Chewy's hat I chew is that
yeah so he would walk out but I've got
some tremendous places to cop I'm gonna
have to write a [ __ ] book mr. wendal
my bat song 20 years ago
there's two and uh black dudes that were
hot no I still went what on YouTube and
put on mr. wendal you remember this
whole deal 44:42 yeah you remember saw
this came out in 93 mr. wendal yeah it
was a black song by a popular black
group wasn't like the Fuji one of those
you know like those they all came oh
yeah yeah yeah what happened to other
guys the Filipino the two black guys in
the chick chick that was married to the
guy on NBC and then he cheated on her
the strip thing she's from the valley
she's from the Vatican yeah you know
yeah the to the de black dude Arrested
Development oh yeah you don't remember
this [ __ ] song Arrested Development's
oh yeah yeah fast-forward this for the
song mr. window see remember
you go so we used to go to a place huh
and then 25th that's goodly I just one
of the memories yes I got no place
hundred twenty fifth and Broadway
memories and he was an old black dude oh
he had to be 70 all he had it was wise
potato chips couple sodas and
bulletproof glass when you went in there
and you'd say what do you got a second
boo the time today tens and twenties I'd
confuse him I'd say give me three tens
in two 20s
he'd go what to twenties and also next
thing on would he would put him under
the thing like seven of them for me to
look at him yeah and I clip-on I had mr.
Wendell down to a science for oh yeah I
was broke broke broke when I go over
that with $28 20 for the bag and hate to
get over him back that's enough for a
hot dog how do I gotta say the first
time I went to a dealers house to buy
coke man was prior I don't think I think
it was wasn't till I was like 90 or so
like that I was in college the dude
scared the piss out of me on purpose to
de lluvia on purpose
so oh dude because he was I went with a
buddy mine and he just said only one I
mean me pointed me was like you come on
I'm so my buddy was again you go way
down the street sorry my friend [ __ ]
walk down the street and I was like damn
him and he had this Doberman lady that
as soon as I walked in just walked right
up to me and followed me
growling the entire time I'm sitting
right there i sat on the couch and the
dog sat right by the edge of the couch
just staring at me growling
and I was like hey this man if this iffy
this is like a bad time or you need you
to come back or whatever I'm happy to do
so
you know if you and lady knee until you
know take a walk or whatever and he was
like no now's a good time he's like what
was that you needed you needed some coke
and I was like yeah I mean I was all
right I'll be right back
and then just hear him go lady stay and
he just disappears in the other room and
the [ __ ] dog is just right there just
staring at me growling and I was just
like what the [ __ ] is about to happen
like III seriously thought if I run for
sure the dog is gonna bite me right like
a hundred percent so I was just sitting
there I'm like I'm just trying to stay
[ __ ] cool in the least bit and then
dude you know was gone felt for like
three four minutes he starts laughs and
he comes back he goes you lasted longer
than most people and I like oh my god
he was lady go and runs away and I was
like roof he was like it was just
testing you man I was like for what he's
like just to see if you were gonna you
know [ __ ] yourself on mic act I
basically did man
wee-bey I basically did [ __ ] myself but
then I never went back and bought coke
from anybody ever again
I always got somebody to get me coke cuz
I was like I'm not [ __ ] coke dealers
were overdue in that [ __ ] my first code
view was Patti d another guy that wore
robe yeah man why-why-why Arora but he
made the best tuna he'd put lemon juice
on he squeezed fresh I mean his tuna cuz
he would offer it to me sometime I'm
gonna go over there till I had this
other detective funniest things happen
when I was young and will go to drug the
things I remember there are many things
I forgot you know the time I went to gut
this house to sell them my [ __ ] bday
well those [ __ ] things where you put
your glasses in the dishes and what
dishwasher no I stole this [ __ ] thing
here go to your mom's houses in the
[ __ ] kitchen she's got a thing that
holds her wedding dishes and silverware
in molasses yeah
I found one that Street when they in a
box me and my friend and we picked them
up and stole it and we brought it to him
and that night I went back to get the
money from him and he had the robe on
and he had to check over there that was
sucking his dick want you to take a [ __ ]
I mean that's what I bumped into those
are the houses that I loved all that
[ __ ]
I mean you go somewhere to get coke and
they got drum over there I love all that
[ __ ] I just thought of a question I
can't believe I've never asked you
before if you add it up everything that
you've stolen ballpark you ever thought
about how much just total price of [ __ ]
you've probably stolen let's get even
kinky
yeah that was sitting there yeah they're
on the plane doing I wonder if I could
cut my nose off and there's like a
ticker in there for how much coke I did
the translated into [ __ ] money
that would because you never remember
the last ten years I paid for everything
like every line that I got from 97 to
[ __ ] thousand seventy by the way with
it you you weren't a let's go out to a
party and I'll put my drugs down got a
guy no that's not what was happening no
I let other people do yeah yeah that was
not your thing no I've been to parties
where people just emptied one bag after
yeah yeah you know that was not your
attempt to impress girls no no no no you
know it's funny because when I stalking
the time I started to the time I went to
prison I stole 70% of that blow I did
stole it from who anybody and everybody
who ever sold coke and I would just set
him up I'd have to Rio for dealers at
one time where we got the weakest on me
[Music]
do you think maybe like it's close to
breaking even between the stealing and
the buying yeah that's a good h-honestly
I just had this thought process on the
way to New York on Thursday on I was
high on JetBlue you don't get heart
yeah and I was like I wondered all
another last year the last three years
all those years in LA Jesus in 2000 on
ez3 400 a week you know that is to spend
fifteen twelve hundred to fifteen like
after 2003 I was spending close to 2000
months between the weed and the holy
[ __ ] and how much you have - let's add
it up a gram of $60 I was doing 2 grams
in night four times a week can I ask you
how much did you weigh when that was
going down who the [ __ ] knows I wasn't
way that way no but we were but like cuz
and then what I always thought was like
how is he
four dude that'd be six hundred a week
times four is twenty four hundred a
month right you figure out was buying
two weights and fave meant for $60 of
[ __ ] that's 120
and I was buying [ __ ] eight grams a
week at $60 that's minimum that's if I
went to let's say I went el compadre
what do 20s in the game in the pure [ __ ]
I wouldn't go back out that night I'll
audition the next day but the last three
years you got to assume I was doing two
grams a night at 60 gram and we run it
every night every the four nights a week
we're gonna dispensaries them because I
know the one to spend is open you owe me
that link and you spend a ton of
dispensaries no hours off of
dispensaries no then after 2004 I got
one of the credit cards back and I
remember one month I put $5,000 at the
dispensary had my wife my wife never
gotten mad at me and nothing like that
you know my wife understands when it
comes to my reefer but that time she sat
me down I'm max Takata it was at $4,800
in a month in a month from the pharmacy
I was dropping three a day I was calling
they're droppin three every two days
every three days
they have lollipops and cookies breath
mints the breath mints they had that
that eights worth $19 in those days guys
the weed was beautiful and there was 19
hours in those days the breath mints
with the for the first edibles to really
[ __ ] me up because they put him right
under your tongue that red strip the
breath strips yeah the breast rip those
are the first ones the best the best
edible back then was cush Lauren had a
taffy I never had that look that I would
just send you to Juba it was ten years
beyond I'd like to know who the [ __ ]
those people were you know you're
getting you know what those things you
get kokand that you have to open those
little zip masks and you have to open
and then you do a bump it was the size
of that it was like a Jolly Rancher like
a little Jolly Rancher was flat and when
you opened it you could actually see the
THC oil on the bottom of the bag like
I'm gonna corner like maybe a 10 but you
could see it when you ate it you weren't
blackout like I always had strong
edibles like I remember when cush large
brownie was death 200 milligrams that
that was killing people I'm a big animal
thing and taking a flight to Pittsburgh
and I couldn't control my legs on the
flight I mean it was painful I couldn't
stop moving my legs it was painful you
understand that 200 milligrams is still
a lot for most people oh yeah but the
other night I gave an agent I had
brought a coinkle knockout could you
punch her she punched
I brought a cushy punch I ate 50 150
milligrams and then I took the square
and I probably ate 30 and I gave him 20
mmm
and I watched him sink he's about 23
okay oh I gave it them before the show
before Dean Delray went up at 120
minutes in he was already the chicken
sandwich with french fries and he wasn't
stopping you know when people either
they're not stopping yeah like they're
putting French
- french fried pickle dippin and ketchup
yeah the whole time they're looking at
you scared like he was taming the animal
and then I went on stage and I lost him
and I asked the other agent how they
doing this bro you got to see him the
rest of the night he was [ __ ] on the
Sun it was terrible
did he take off I think yeah he went
Rams killed people well I gotta work
yourself up to it so no way you could I
like those deca dos cheaper juice that's
what I like one baby
yeah it's like 175 yeah that's basically
where I like that's like a [ __ ] burp
for us I know it is it's crazy I still
remember when I was getting the wrapper
I was getting a 180 from me I would eat
the 180 and I would take the wrapper
from the 180 all right however I would
take the 180 take it out and open the 60
and I'd take the 60 out of that and I'd
put the 180 and a 62 TV I'll give it to
ya and this was the very beginning at
the office and he would try to convince
me that I was going crazy like you know
it's only 60 more dreams he was training
yeah I guess no I actually original
question yet I don't know if the drug
deal was interesting like I'm gonna bind
weed off a guy that had snakes
what yes thanks yeah I like that all
over the [ __ ] house you know and then
come in and he go - this is good be
careful one of my Boas are loose playing
it's a poisonous thing yeah yeah yeah he
would have them running around yeah yeah
no [ __ ] that
no thank you that's usually that type of
[ __ ] yeah you know [ __ ] it are in the
snake if you've ever been on truck and
you watched that drug scene with Boogie
Nights
that's five in the morning on a coke
dealers address you saw that same way no
you've never seen that st. no I haven't
do you haven't seen bug in it no this is
why but I'll call him and his girlfriend
are watching the worst television or TV
you could have a dream you have to watch
this movie nights it
I'm even scared to ask what he watches
names a funny thing we could sit here
and talk about boogie night yeah and
free he'll still go home and have the
audacity to watching black is the new
orange or something like that you put on
Boogie Nights oh you have to watch
buckets Chinese scene whatever the [ __ ]
they call it firecracker firecracker
scene lead slip Daly you're gonna get a
list in the week and your nose in order
yeah
whether she likes to or not you have got
to watch but it's like this is what
you're watching tonight with you this is
what's on this TV tonight that if you
want to watch something else go to the
other TV Olivia mother's house on West
Telemundo like what this is what we'll
watch it here today Burt Reynolds in
that movie although they're all [ __ ]
fantastic so Reynolds is the [ __ ]
best in that movie you find it I think
so I was called Jesse's girl yes yeah
but you know everybody's fantastic in
this movie there's not a bad [ __ ]
actor in this goddamn movie the guy the
child pornographer oh yeah everybody the
roller skate girl
what's this Lee Philip Seymour Hoffman
Philip Seymour Hoffman only the guys on
spider-man Marky Wahlberg no why would
we do this this is how am I supposed to
know if I've never heard of it you've
never heard of the movie no but you got
time to watch our ingenue black and
although this [ __ ] oh my god I mean so
dad is exactly what you're saying that's
what you miss that's what I don't miss
that's the action that I missed for
years so I always was looking for four
years I missed that type of [ __ ]
nonsense where you go back for a second
oh geez okay okay but like that's why
for me the story you don't have to deal
with so this is such a good movie yeah
and so many [ __ ] levels because it
shows the guy getting picked up as a way
to get into Poland blowing up at the
point that scene with the chick and
him and that there's the chick with the
tool woman in the room
rollers Corral and the white chick
that's redhead with freckles yeah she
should have want to Academy Award for
that coaxing right Julianne Moore
Julianne Moore the guy the second one
twenty five great boogie leg quotes that
guy right there that plays the [ __ ]
pervert to child molester yeah this is a
[ __ ] tremendous great this is your
next assignment Friday night I want it I
want it before Friday
how how it's three hours oh is it really
okay it's deep I put it on this end
and I'll tell you Bertrand like I get
again Burt Reynolds is so damn business
Burrell's is good he did it the colonel
was saying you know about my name uh-huh
I was just wondering if you had any
ideas I had some thoughts on it yeah
what about you what do you think well my
idea was you know just want a name I
wanted to looking cut glass you know
like razor sharp razor sharp yeah well
when I close my eyes I see this thing
this big sign and the name is in like
bright blue neon lights with like purple
outline and this name is just so bright
so sharp that the sign it just blows up
because the name is just so powerful
[Music]
what is going on I think he's a way to
have but rebels fix him up he shows his
dick he gets him into porn because he
wants he's always wanted to be in porn
yeah yeah well he's a broke kid he quit
high school then this guy's the child
pornographer
oh thank god Chile he goes to jail
eventually eventually yeah so yeah I
didn't even consider when I was like no
even weed I was always scared that I'd
pick go to the one dealer that was an
undercover cop I didn't even consider
that it was craziness like I figured
that one a lot of business and get
people out of there they would make you
watch them dance to buy coke to guys oh
no when the Martell cartel was
originally the Martell cartel was
originally two black dudes but then they
got robbed there was two black dudes in
the white dude but then somebody robbed
them and I became alliance with them
because I gave him a good but then the
dude I gave the gun to took off so I got
stuck with the black dude brought out
the white dude because he didn't want to
get shot at no more Martell and they
didn't want to get tied up anymore ha ha
ha ha what he did was the black dude
stayed and he got a Russian girlfriend
but to make ends meet
he hired a superhero you can't write
this [ __ ] from Hollywood hired a
superhero the Hulk he's black
yeah and the Hulk lived in his closet
under the stairs so at night I go with
her buy coke and you'd see two little
black feet on the bottle he killed
somebody but dragged them neck in first
and I go broke ooh and then I walk I
still see the hook once he and he gives
me a big hug where you see him walking
around Hollywood or the comedy store he
came in one night gave me a big hug he
started this [ __ ] thing I will place the
Hulk on Hollywood Boulevard so live
understand I used to look under that
yeah like a picture of his mom on the
wall a little light you've seen the
videos of those those guys fighting down
there beating the [ __ ] out of each other
like though when those two ladies attack
spongebob last year did you see that
oh my god did it right no it ain't right
it on some [ __ ] kids attack Holly
wheat Halloween one time jerseys all my
friends gonna talk didn't they beat up
the guy who plays Superman
oh how fun yeah like he has no teeth now
like they really he can't even be
Superman anymore no not so Superman I I
used to when I came out here and used to
live with Scott out by Dodger Stadium
and my buddy Neil you know I used to
entertain a children's parties and so
but when you put that costume on people
will whatever you're supposed to be
they'll be like when you were a Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtle they would punch you
and kick you what yeah I mean kids oh
gee and people think it's funny so I can
only imagine how much [ __ ] they get
walking around in like a Superman
costume on Hollywood Boulevard where
your gum you're bound to run into some
[ __ ] well have you say have you seen
the guy on the strip in Vegas who lets
people kick him in the nuts for 20 bucks
what yeah the [ __ ] yeah and everything
he's wearing a cup I don't know I didn't
do it I don't think so
wait a second wait a second I would take
a swing at somebody for 20 for 20 bucks
100 and kick him I mean not what he's
there and I go out a twelve-week [ __ ]
kicking spree I joined soccer I'd do
everything I can to kick as hard as I
thought okay there's a bunch of YouTube
videos of it really yeah and people just
I would go toe up oh god I had way it
doesn't wear a cup I don't know about
that and we're right there so it's it
seemed and you saw it I saw him I didn't
I didn't I don't want to see anyone get
kicked in the balls
I mean once he was getting kicked in the
nuts a white dude this guy yep we're
getting kicked in the balls for 20 bucks
in Las Vegas this is easy if front of
Harrah's kick me in the nuts with $20
he's got a sign this our country is
getting weirder and weirder
oh Jesus Christ
Oh
and he's high five hundred drugs what
drugs is that dude didn't he has he got
to hold the sign I mean how much no cop
no joke how much is he I mean yeah how
much does that guy get paid what kind of
cat gotta make three bills a day easy
you gotta go home put your balls in ice
and he's gotta have some kind of harness
on he has to he you can't let a grown
man take a running kick like that at
your nuts and then just kind of brush it
off is that a thing maybe he taped it
down or something me actually someone I
remember the only to put up you can't
[ __ ] do that and that catches bullet
was teeth why would I want to see what
they have on that guy but that's the
same thing like there's no way that
happens he's got to have the bullet in
his mouth already right
no he puts a mouth guard in it was it
was a [ __ ] weird tell they shoot it
into his mouth
via black and white yeah this guy was
when I was growing up and he got he used
to do all the errand there was a
promoter in New York that did martial
arts at the garden all day event kungfu
and how he would close the show is the
guy getting shot
they put a glass in front of him you see
the contact of the bullet going through
with a 22 and then he would put up
[ __ ] mouthpiece of his mouth and
catch it and catch it and he got shot
eventually there's only one way to
practice that yeah
there's no way to practice yeah you know
it was the 70 so it could have been
[ __ ] ten magicians who died on stage
Oh Joey would love that that that was
one of the hardest nights I've ever
laughed is when Steve Simone and Joey
had magic done in front of them and they
both right I was there left the room are
you talking about onstage at no I'm
talking about it at dinner
Oh me yeah at that Christmas party we
went to they had a magician there
gabriel's yeah
and then you and Steve both like
couldn't do it I don't know by you man
magician friends nah I can't mine t I've
never really been over crazy about
magician yeah and then I had a magician
friend and he was out of his mind like
he made me look like a [ __ ] door
prize drug wise alcohol wise you know
everything why's he out there bad you
know yeah well I think you would
probably [ __ ] it have to be right he was
but he was one of the 10 best comics in
the were 10 best magicians in the world
at one time I mean he showed me all this
[ __ ] him hanging up and dipp'd throw him
in the ocean in a barrel time water
chains that type of [ __ ] you know oh he
was one of those escape artists oh yeah
skate magic bar magic he was the real
[ __ ] deal you know obvious magician
what I don't have used to rob a magician
listen to me and somebody ratted me out
what's that what happened to him
you see I'm saying about this podcast
game about life in Los Angeles that
you'll see somebody every week for three
years and then one week poof they
disappear yeah who was the kid that was
tweeting us and he was at all.i shows
the white kid white kid then a boxer no
then he started going to [ __ ] the
Late Show at the Comedy Store he really
liked Don's barrel Jordan Lee where is
he
I don't know I he was here for a while
doing that weird how that happens you
know and you bump into him a year later
and you feel bad because they dropped
out of your life yeah yes rot sorry Alya
and things happen in LA things really
happen that you get caught up you meet a
new girlfriend you get a job and you go
to Mexico for three months they call you
on Monday tell you how to be in Mexico
on Wednesday you ain't got time to tell
all your friends goodbye mm-hmm so you
being the [ __ ] you call that person
three times he never returns your calls
please I didn't get the messages and you
know like [ __ ] and one day you're
calling me oh [ __ ] you you [ __ ] Punk
I never like get anywhere I [ __ ] your
sister in the ass yeah then he'll call
you a year later no dawg which one were
you I was in Mexico yeah
Boyka [ __ ] you [ __ ] but you know what
else happens in this town too sometimes
you realize you're like holy [ __ ] I
haven't seen mark in three months you
didn't he's just go he's gone
got off the [ __ ] it happened I
totally even with a podcast game we've
been doing that now for six years people
come they go they drift they come back
you know that's our nature mm-hmm well I
was never like that growing up I never
listened to the [ __ ] radio anyway I
just switched between three stations
today I listen to Sirius v I got serious
right he lethea with you yeah lets him
lithium yeah Ozzy's boneyard Jim Norton
is jim Florentine and studio 54 I got
hits from the 70s and that's it
I got hits from the eighties hits from
the main mass or someone you do any
hip-hop stations like 45 or any of that
nothing nothing
ah see I've figured out late in life
that I'd like I am kind of a homebody
like I like being at my house and but
also you know when I go now to a
restaurant I get this I'm like an old
man I got the same [ __ ] thing
everywhere I go I'm not gonna go I don't
go
once I find something I like on the menu
that's it for that that's what I order
at that place what I never know you know
I was the last time you went to the
conveyer belt
Hado when was the last time you I don't
play one well you weren't watching you
never went back
you follow me so you want to undercut
yourself to the best place you could go
to for your convenience and for your
time but you never want back anyway and
you've gone to 15 of those restaurants
so number one you don't build no loyalty
nowhere and the places you do build
loyalty in a garbage anyway you're
following Xanthia loyalty and the other
walks on where I want to 7-Eleven and I
see some Mexican chicken she goes whoa
where you been lately I don't know what
she was trying on mango what are you
talking about she was you haven't come
to get you clearly the tacos lately I
felt like a man because I built a
loyalty over then she was right where
the [ __ ] am I bit but I lose weight but
but but that you that's one of the top
things that you do you've always done no
you don't [ __ ] mean you've always
somebody delivers the goods I don't give
a [ __ ] what you have to offer I just
went home this last weekend and when I
go home I have three or four things that
need to be done they need to be done I
have a dear friend George I love him
he's my brother if I ever had a brother
he's one of my brothers but at every
restaurant he doesn't understand that
I'm gonna [ __ ] pick him up and one
day it's gonna happen and I'm gonna
[ __ ] stab him with a [ __ ] knife
because there's always a place that's
better
but it's 90 miles away but since he's a
jerk-off and he likes all that type of
you know he likes war and you know he
wants did they like that I keep it basic
my first place off the thing this
Thursday was Chan's dragon in plain and
simple did you know what you were
getting on your way there on the way
there hell yeah and the people who were
coming I know what they like because I
went there with them before the one girl
who was shown I used to go there with
her we weren't even dating but she was
such a Chinese fan and I was a Chinese
fan we'd run together and when we meet
on the house we shower meet other house
mm-hmm and we can go to Chan's and get a
pork fried rice to spareribs and we
share it we were kids yeah but that's
what you do yeah the owner when he saw
me we you know he hugged me how many is
and then we told there was a girl at the
table that her father was the baseball
coach Lisa Gallo and I told Lisa the
evolution of driver ed in our school for
some reason the local Cadillac dealer
gave our school two Cadillacs and they
put pedals in them so during your gym
class yeah
junior year you could start instead of
going to gym one day a week you sign up
and you go driving for the one quarter
for three months you drive but you got
to sign your name on the list
at 7:30 in the morning for the same time
with the same people right trouble with
Josh won't sign up for seven sign up for
9:45 so we tossed
why would you want to go with three
people you don't know so me you Lee and
[ __ ] Bert Kreischer would sign up so
our Spri would sit in the back limits in
the front then the teacher would sit
then we'd switch
so the teacher would started the program
at first was mr. McGrath yeah and he was
out of his mind he was a football coach
you know he was I was mine so I first
had started very simple you got in the
car at the high school he's pulled over
by Kennedy Boulevard somewhere and then
you switched then you drove for 12
minutes then we drove for 12 minutes but
it always ended up in the Ridgefield
Circle and that was where the last stop
was that's the last place when the last
driver would get in and then a block
before the school he would get it and
yeah I've gone through a lot that was
insurance rules the only problem with
the Ridgefield Circle is it's the home
to the best they got a Dairy Queen there
[Laughter]
60 yards from the Dairy Queen is the
world's greatest Chinese restaurant in
the country Chan's dragon it all right
plain and simple
yeah working man we would either so it's
try that slow it's a commercial come on
mr McGrath problem pull over Dairy Queen
while we're switching I was gonna call
and it's against prop it's against rules
come on McGrath what's a [ __ ] call
what kind of calling whenever and next
thing you know we're sitting in a
Ridgefield Circle eating the [ __ ]
cards I carry up guys we gotta get back
you know and that started like that that
went on for like a week to two weeks but
the Chinese restaurant was just down the
block
so we all hopped in instead of doing the
9:30 to 10:15 yeah we did the 1016 we
did the we did the 11 to 11:45 get so
much chance would open up an iPad so we
get that set after 11:00 and mr. Kraft
we go to Richfield Circle why this time
yeah let's switch it up as we switch
left to chance dragon book is no crap
[Laughter]
in there we were told look at this oh
you know I don't take pictures yeah cuz
they're not worth it I look at my menu
on the [ __ ] I'm gonna the menu on
JetBlue Mint you're ready for what you
choose to eat this is what he takes
pictures I've sees what they give you
when you sit down yeah Jeff movement let
me read you [ __ ] the menu let
me explain some to people I fly like a
Puerto Rican but when I go to New York
it's a six hour flight I saved my
JetBlue points and I get one way I pay
for one the other way I get for free
that's the only way I can do this flight
welcome the first may open up with is a
white peach and raspberry smoothie
especially you've had a star three stars
in the [ __ ] yeah they give you fresh
fruit orange kiwi and pomegranate
pomegranate they pick it out a race you
just eat one by one like I'm granting a
time and then they gave you a chart
carrot salad my wife wasn't that then
corn chowder with bacon and smoked
paprika paprika oil little bits of bacon
and [ __ ] corn Charlie like six am a
6:35 then you wait wait this was
breakfast this was breakfast this is
bright this was the first serving you
ready for this one we you ready hmm
coconut pancakes with mango pineapple
and ginger wine made syrup you had an
appetizer from breakfast that's what
they give you dishes wishes in your
sample all of them and then they also
gave you a goat cheese with tomato
omelette I gave that to the fat [ __ ] a
[Laughter]
double expresso twice to give him a
[ __ ] meal going on the plane because
I was too high oh my god and then they
brought me a cool house sorbet from Los
Angeles California but she brought me a
little Weight Watchers for like a little
coke dealer spoon yeah I totally they go
listen take this back in the real sport
your [ __ ] thing yes the hong kong's
by the way they [ __ ] get me I hate
those little spoons you know what else I
hate those um every crawfish every
crawfish yeah I I can't I don't
understand it because do it there's too
much work and there's no you can eat a
pile of those [ __ ] do this and that's
it there's something I like crawfish I'm
not putting nobody done I've had plenty
of Bunyan and Houston Texas the best
place to get them ever and then it gets
nice great it tastes great but but you
know what let's fight them off so let's
go for them you give me no big me you
give me the micro give me the macro I
got a clue I got a micro cat at the
house I want the macro want the [ __ ]
was a little taste good it's just the
returns or not it's too much work it's
way too much work I can't do the shrimp
like this from cocktails that they have
the legs on them still I don't like that
I like it peeled yeah you can but you
can just take let me ask you something
what when somebody gives me shrimp I
don't give a [ __ ] if I get the eyeball
okay you know why cuz somewhere there's
a [ __ ] person eating the [ __ ] sand
dog so what like if you go to ah there's
a place in North Bergen bro that I don't
[ __ ] with too much because I don't have
the money to go in there mm-hmm but my
friends have to have money took me in
there and when they give you shrimp Lee
damn like 19 shrimp because three inches
is the head with the eyes it's the real
shrimp I'll narrow and you just take the
thing off just quite and they crunch it
up for ya
no I got talk to you guys about
something that's a guarantee people turn
this podcast on while all this is tohara
painting on it we thought because I
kidnapped the [ __ ] and put him
in the trunk of a car but my face never
made it to the cover of the newspaper
and when I was in New York Saturday and
I walked around there and I saw every
[ __ ] newspaper with Louis CK's
picture on it
it [ __ ] hit home like it it didn't
hold for me I just said to myself Jesus
Christ I put some money trunk icon I
made the page like 8 it was just a
little blurb I'm gonna [ __ ] car
dealer and you know it's different it's
a different time and Louise like that
was at the top of the pyramid yeah I
mean I mean all these allegations every
[ __ ] day you get a new allegation and
you know what meant the thing that
bothers a gal like me is people can
allege [ __ ] every [ __ ] day
but today's world it ruins your career
you know when somebody comes to me and
says Lee took that dick out early I'm
gonna check it out if I open my mouth I
mean I'm gonna [ __ ] check it out I'm
saying right but Louie it maybe check it
out right right he admitted it and then
you know there's a big thing but it's
just not Louie it's just everything
about Richard's right for Scott accused
of something I saw that and this guy got
the president George were the first Bush
isn't getting accused all the time now
and yeah he got accused again today yeah
and what do you call it uh who else got
accused today you say Richard Dreyfuss
who wasn't today but they got from Star
Trek yeah George Takei also Dustin
Hoffman - that's [ __ ] crazy George
Takei but now what's the situation in
George Takei's it's like a male-model or
something I guess there's something that
maybe you gotta remember something that
movie Liberace came on HBO yeah I went
somewhere like that movie really [ __ ]
with me a little bit because I really
knew the truth I looked I looked at it
for what it was
you know Liberace first of all for
people who I don't want you to look at
this time in Hollywood as oh my god was
going on Hollywood listen
they passed Marilyn Monroe I don't like
a [ __ ] dummy doll
okay and many others of those women they
passed around they just passed around
them
Marilyn Monroe is the biggest disgrace
in American history she was [ __ ] the
president a gangster and God knows who
else along the way God knows who walks
along the way you know yeah you know
Sinatra what do you think he did to
women he told that one lady to get a
hanger when she was pregnant
it's crazy who are out of a house we
said go to the [ __ ] yeah I didn't
forget you pregnant you know statements
like that [ __ ] like that you know I just
I believe in [ __ ] you know I've
always been on the other side of the
coin and sometimes it's been me
and sometimes you you're accused just
for being who you are yeah yeah you know
and that's wood then there's another
tactic to this that bothers me that
really [ __ ] bothers me because people
in this room will attest to this we
change every five years
oh yeah a few chains we get smarter we
get wiser you know you don't do the dumb
[ __ ] you used to do leave even nice kid
are you a different person than you were
five years ago 100% and which way and
which ways are you a better person now
that you were five years ago
I just think when you're at least for me
you're in such a bubble and high school
in college that you don't really realize
you just I mean you there's a difference
between being polite and acting like a
good person and I'm still there's still
some things that I that could do better
I'm not gonna lie but I I think that you
learn through just dealing with people
how to act and you see how other people
act you know go like that I didn't like
when someone did that but you still
there's things you can change but used
if you did something 10 15 20 years ago
there still can be consequences for that
do you know what I mean like I
understand that people change but that
can't completely exonerate you for
things you might have done in you
and you're past that little just weren't
brave enough to say anything
look at this judge right now who's
something like 70 and they're saying 40
years ago he dated kids in high school
and even one of the in the article if
you read the article it said like the
mom told one of her told the daughter oh
I think you're the luckiest girl in the
world to date Roy Moore and she was 14
so it is yeah like yeah he might argue
in the thing is he's denying it but he
might argue like listen it wasn't that
big of a deal back then or I don't know
maybe maybe it was I don't know I don't
know with that one but yeah right I
think I think if you I'm just saying
like I'm not saying that you can't
change em everybody changes they're
saying what you've done yeah just
because you change because whatever you
did if you did it whatever you did
change somebody else for the worse right
and I so there has to be some sort of
repercussion for that no matter what how
long ago it was like if you did
something to somebody that changed their
life for the worse that [ __ ] them up
and continues to do that then no matter
how long it is you still got to pay for
that [ __ ] right and that was what I took
away from the Loess thing so far is I
got he even said in his apology whatever
you think of it he didn't realize from
the like their point of view and I think
that's kind of hard to do is take the
other person's point of view and I think
like even with him when he says oh I I
never touched anybody who didn't want to
who I always asked it's still terrible
from imagine being 21 and you don't want
to say no mm-hmm you're just out here
you all you want to do is get the job
you you don't know if I gonna get fired
for saying no so it's a it must be scary
yeah I yeah I'm sure I'm sure it's
really scary and that's why I'm not
saying that like I I understand why some
people wouldn't come out I understand
why it takes people a long time to come
out
I listen are you a hundred percent
I've been propositioned by men
women like it for sure happens for sure
and it's terrible and and I think that
the more that people come out I think
it'll just scare the [ __ ] out of paper
ones or not because there was nothing
there was no repercussions before nobody
was saying [ __ ] but on the other side of
that coin and both of you are married
but maybe you have single friends I
don't know in this day and age if you
were gonna date somebody now in the
industry would you have them sign
something what do you have them like if
you're gonna hook up with a girl on the
road what do you have them signs like it
just
that's that terrifies me I don't know
what you mean like just just to be like
yeah like this is legit like we're not
forcing you into this with like just I
don't know I'm just shocked about the
whole thing I'm in shock about you know
allegations bother the [ __ ] out of me
you know I want proof with you I'm with
you you know it's you and I in a room I
mean the Loess thing happened in 2002
who knew where his sickness was listen
you just don't stand in front of a door
take your shirt any pants off to take
your dick out and bang around the front
of them by the way that sounds in
terrible that's too will literal to
witnesses
yes sickness was at the highest level of
all time what was he thinking was gonna
happen I mean my heart cause I don't
know insane nothing bad about Louie what
I'm saying is I'm looking at it from
that perspective it came out a little
bit after that there was more
allegations major COFF on the phone with
people which I've done a thousand times
myself she told you she's gonna go in
the shower and you tell her really you
know whatever next thing you know you
got your dick in your hand and you're
breathing heavy for two minutes when the
[ __ ] knows I mean all these things we
all do man they're simple and we don't
think we're doing something with dick
create consequence you know the women
how they filled all that [ __ ]
not going into the politics of law I'm
just going into politics how this ends
you and how you have to bounce back with
a certain wood well I don't think it
should have to end him though that's it
then you said if he does a story short
The Comedy Store tomorrow so if he truth
if they if they said Louise is gonna be
in the main room tomorrow what he said
with all the tickets he would sell all
the tickets of course he's gonna tell
his side of the story what if he this is
what I would do I would wait six months
yeah
I love six months write something and go
on broke my head tell my side of the
story
yeah off-off-broadway dated what I mean
is is I don't think I think this is a
[ __ ] catastrophic thing for sure and
I can't imagine what he's going through
but his kids but but you know he also
put other people through [ __ ] so but but
here but what I mean is now what was the
last time he jerked off well in all the
articles what was the last around you
know I mean never sell about Courtney
Cox they were producing the show and
they were Cori but I think it's a little
different with with him because he he's
admitted to it he's not saying I said
well no no I'm happy admit me yeah thank
God but what I mean is I don't think
this ends his career I think I really
don't think it ends his career you know
he could sell out wherever tomorrow
night even if he just was going on stage
to do stand-up but do you think it would
end someone's career maybe at your
guys's level of comedy because he just
he was a star as a star yeah I I think
it'll affect it obviously affect his
career for the worst obviously but I
hope your bad fake allegations
eventually not a good [ __ ] feeling
but listen to this man and this is why I
was laughing I went to eat Chinese food
with the girls
mmm and my buddy and then from there I
went to my several great pizzas bought I
hope that we kids I went to the sixth
grade with Sergio nari and [ __ ] this
kid Dilma pre-teen lip-read was with me
when I cut my father this is when I was
cutting the wiffle ball bat
to put the socks in it and rocks to make
it heavy to hit homeruns nutrient he was
with me there was another chick there a
bunch of us were there just talking [ __ ]
I forgot my [ __ ] point was you were
talking about allegations yeah yeah
allegation and then my buddy came along
the jury stenographer why he's on the
other side I didn't know that so I won't
no one gave my two great friends hugs
the Undertaker the one that owns the
these in assembly men yeah the
freeholder and I gave my buddy Devo a
big hug he'll if if this other guy I
know
oh [ __ ] and he got up and gave me a big
[ __ ] hug and the invited remember his
name yeah yeah well you forgot and then
93 he was like a big shot and he always
used to know ace to go into the city
kept me alive that kid those days that's
what I was the real financial trouble
and he was a big shot that he didn't
want nobody know he was as much as the
fiend as I was in those bags
anything now going to New York City he
couldn't do any of those snacks but he
knew I know how to keep my mouth shut so
he would come over and go get me for how
I was worth I can get 200 for yourself
so he gave me 200 cash to get myself
that was six grands that dude had a
badass career in the end of there was a
DUI DUI [ __ ] got [ __ ] up DUI ended
everything from now he became some mouse
and so as soon as he saw me you ever got
DUI no no I won't drink and get behind
the wheel now you never did that no I
give them a big hug give me hug because
listen before you leave do me a favor
because when they're walked past the
fire station by my house I heard your
voice laughing that way there we go
what are you listening to the guy's like
he's [ __ ] crazy from Jersey somewhere
and he goes do me a favor if you take a
picture of me and mean the world to me I
got to me a favor I'll owe you 20 years
let me hang out for a while then we'll
take a picture because if I take a
picture with you everybody else will see
it and then I'm not gonna be able to sit
here right this is my own damn bar yeah
yeah they're in the back eating that
chose the French fries this [ __ ] so
finally my buddy from something goes do
me a favor I will take a picture with
the [ __ ] guy his feelings are and I
go it's nothing like him it's that if I
take a picture with him so I went oh
like well you still get a [ __ ]
you still smoke with he goes yeah I'm
[ __ ] you I don't want your picture I
go come on let's go smoke a joint
then I grab them by the arm let go
explain to you but if I take a picture a
bunch of kids in there yeah they were
all gonna come over let me just relax
because I get him we started talking and
we smoked the joy like Oh crazy world
over a kid it's a curse I know I had
looked at you and he guys met my wife
I'm not married I'm no how could you be
I used to stay out three days on the
[ __ ] row back there he was like a
bank shot man and it was just my stall
until he was eight that day something I
don't know if you know this he goes
what's his name confessed to robbing
that house and I go what are you told me
it was you know that house I took you to
leave that you taped in North Bergen
right I said that was the final straw
like when they accused me of Ron yeah
and that was the end now people really
didn't know my friends I went to London
to listen I tell you what I robbed right
yeah give you a piece of the egg yeah I
never robbed a half and then like who
could have done it I knew exactly who
was in her window and they even set me
up she was a step ahead of me and I
didn't see it but I never said no it
didn't matter you know what if I would
have tried to fight it I had all my
friend at that time and you had to get
out of there at that time I couldn't get
myself either anything I was just a
piece of [ __ ] I was robbed and everybody
so I had no leg to stand on but I always
knew in my heart I didn't rob that house
or guess what that kid got busted and he
wanted information that's one of the
things he told me he was involved with
insurance camp and he broke into that
house and my friend found that two days
later cause he knows cops and they were
like that whole time he blamed on koco's
I just wanna tell you I thought I got my
other two friends out they go when I
told you right after it happened look at
the confirmation yeah he gave it up
they're looking at an insurance scam and
30 years ago now so that accusation
always makes me feel like I [ __ ] hate
accusations man well if you but on the
other hand where there's smoke there's
fire
yeah so if I I'm gonna sit here and
believe one thing and believe another
one it's interesting because the last
two days on Twitter every for Twitter
this is about somebody's making a remark
about what's gonna come out as all that
stuff with Corey Feldman and Corey Haim
that was crazy on the video and with
Alyssa Milano was that today or
yesterday
no but then people were people were
accusing her of turning a blind eye to
whatever happened to corey haim or corey
feldman because she hung around them
back then she was a kid too like she was
what 15 or 16 also that's the tough
thing too if you look lay out this and
I'm gonna sound psychology neither of
you you've had you've seen three kids
grow you have a little bit more
knowledge than I do
I was a kid on the street so I look at
faces and I know what they feel
if you don't look at Corey Feldman and
you can't tell that he was my he was
like the animal from the drugs they just
abused him you won't guess what he
wanted to be abused he let them abuse
him that was the only way he could be
accepted well take your clothes off
dance with the boys you wanna stay at
the party he's got a big movie coming
out in September with Brad Pitt stick
around dance for the boys I mean he
didn't he didn't want to he was a kid he
wasn't that what you think I'm saying
yeah they take these kids you could tell
I know when you see a kid and they've
been beat up ya know he's I mean locked
up you ever see a kid when they being
beat up you don't need to see the scars
no you see the beating on their face
yeah and it doesn't have to be a mental
guy a beating with a stick it could be a
mental beating he's gone through hell I
had on my face for years I know exactly
what it looks like and what I feel like
men
so in Corey Haim look because that was
the act I wasn't out there like glory
him know the the accusation was that
chara wasn't the Charlie Sheen I don't
know an accusation like something like
that Charlie Sheen had sex with Corey
Haim was the accusation
that was the accusation that somebody
leveled out there that way yeah man that
on the set of bully bully is that the
name of the movie I think bully on a set
of bully that was the accusation yeah
they're flying all over the place you
didn't hear about that one
no yeah they're flying over you know but
Corey Hamrick I said he just seems like
a kid that he went down the wrong Street
at the wrong time he wasn't mentally
prepared and between the drugs and the
wife and just Patman but you would see
less than zero
yeah well I know you didn't see less
than zero it's one of Robert Downey jr.
his best [ __ ] I so yeah best movies [ __ ]
[ __ ] you with Iron Man [ __ ] your mother
up the ass you [ __ ] [ __ ] I'm talking
about pound for pound acting in that
movie he was brilliant and did you see
how they treat him with that wallet oh
yeah he be just do go and the guy would
bring him to parties and he blow guys
and [ __ ] guys I'm late come on I'll give
you all the coke you want hey here you
go
let's go to a party there's no missing
guys that way to me they're very
important
and then I don't have a big bag of co2
so you're gonna go in the room with him
and talk I'm gonna rub your thigh
there you are sucking that dick and then
he would take him give him more coke
what was his name that movie I remember
that was again I might go back and watch
that no no I was all about a month ago
at 2:00 and I taped him once in the next
day and it was he was brilliant man he
dies [ __ ] I mean it was just brilliant
he was a a great drug addict the drool
coming out of the side well he was a
great drug addict because he yeah he was
living it living it at the time it was
but when I look at that I see I saw that
yeah you don't think I saw that in my
circles young whenever this happens this
guy solo it's on when you live in San
Francisco
85 and when I look at Aspen I saw all
the time hey man your way that hando
this Marky Wahlberg story you write that
from something you saw but that's how
quick it happens are the Boogie Nights
is like Scarface for portly it's a kid
that works in the valley guy comes in
one night he [ __ ] a waitress that tells
him that he's got a big dick and you
know he sees him and the rest is history
then you see that you saw that scene in
the hot tub where he named where do you
where he get picks his porn name
right he becomes until he becomes he
wins the newcomer of the Year sastra job
that's doing drugs and he's gone and I
see me and they the lady right before I
got arrested that was me from 87 to
right foot point I got arrested 86 to 87
with her
that was me Marky Wahlberg God talking
to myself yeah Jhansi right the entire
cast but John the john c reilly to me
goes between comedy and serious better
than anybody
he did it he doesn't in the movie but he
slips in between got a [ __ ] sing I
feel the heat feel that he they think
they really have a soul come on
and they gotta bring the tapes to the
album guy those are two gun coked up
guys
with a dream of 60,000 yeah they got a
kilo of coke you see it that's how good
of the acting it's really cuz I've been
there I've been there you to feel the
heat feel the heat that's one of the
best things in the movie for sure or
there in the court and he's got his
hands up to the to the headphones it's
pretty crazy and he's terrible and
they're giving him the all the other guy
yeah he is like [ __ ] Plano like he's
Jimmy paid the guitar is [ __ ] it's just
a coked-up scene it's like Goodfellas
and he comes home and he's looking for
ELQ and they both start crying and she's
on the hands and knees no junkies you
know just to junkies I've been there
it's a [ __ ] [ __ ] when I had that
when I had that my ex-wife you know when
I had that $60,000 debt and Aspen we
were looking at each other towards the
end and we had the same way that we just
broke down she felt bad you know I
wasn't coming home at night I wouldn't
just go to Josh I'm gonna yo Josh what's
gonna take for you to leave what
I got a quarter ounce of coke let alone
nobody arrests that's yeah that was your
move what is gonna take a leaf easily
give me your apartment tonight because I
was paranoid to be in mind so I thought
they were watching me so I come to you
in a date then I go away I'm gonna give
me 200 bucks tonight I'll bring a case
of beer with the else we'll go switch
cars
I'm gonna pull it to your house with my
car you're gonna open up the garage and
you're gonna leave with my car and go to
the hotel over there on the Lankershim
and keep them there all night and I'm
gonna go to your house and do blow and
let me tell you some with an hour I'd be
calling you don't come over and get me
the cops again comes with you to go it's
not just days of the house I am so glad
you know I did coke a bunch but mostly
with you I never liked it I never really
liked it there was a couple of times I
can remember having fun but I'm so glad
I never really liked it and I did that
meth just that once hated that you're
doing Boise no I did it by accident I
thought it was coke
I didn't Boise I didn't Boise
Bakersfield sometimes I did it I hoped
it was coke now what's next for louis
c.k I mean the agency got rid of him
it's like Kevin Spacey Kevin Spacey's
not getting out of this one what happens
to he's shooting a movie that's coming
out and dismember yeah I did see that on
the point but here's what happens I
think with louis c.k I think he goes
away for a while I think he does I think
he probably ends up in some sort of
therapy slash rehab thing that he puts
himself in I think he comes out without
representation I think while he's in
rehab he writes whatever it is a new
hour whether it's more you know half
theater half comedy or full comedy but I
think he'll come out and even if he has
to just release it on YouTube
because the best thing about being a
comic so you can never really fire us do
you I mean that's the difference with
our job that anybody else is like [ __ ]
it so you're gonna pay me I'm still
gonna go get on stage he could sell I'm
telling you when he gets out of jail
they're not at jail but when he gets out
of rehab or where he puts himself and if
he's there are fans of his that'll come
see him the only problem is is like now
with how people can I don't know what
the word is but gathers the storm they
could like it like let's say a random
comedy club wanted to put them up there
might be people online saying let's
boycott them let's let's let's get them
their lease cancelled like people will
go that far now and so you might have a
trouble of getting somewhere
I think the more that happens the more
support he would garner I really do I
think there are a bunch of people who
are pretty fed up with that like
whatever is this is and this I I used to
have this conversation when it came to
Mike Vick whatever you thought of his
punish of his crime or punishment it
Vick got what he got he went to jail he
came out he gets to start over you can't
still make him pay for his crime so
Louie is gonna pay however he's gonna
pay and then with whatever happens in I
don't know if there'll be lawsuits I
don't know if it'll just be in the fact
that he'll never be who knows who knows
what the pay is but then he still gets
to try to make a living doing what he
does that I don't think we should ever
take that away from people do you know
what I mean like I still think you
should be able to do whatever it is that
you do now you may have to do it in much
smaller scale or you may not succeed at
it but I don't think we take people's
ability away to do it you know what I'm
saying you might have to start a podcast
oh yeah maybe he will keep this thought
was Tony Bennett
I mean I wanna be around I want to give
a shout-out to sherry and her son
beautiful people came to the show in New
York tre Robert Benjamin Paul Jacob
Lindbergh Anthony Johnson holding it up
in Sactown jabish Oakland Pittsburgh the
hidden choice
Alejandro X SC south ASCO Robin McGehee
and my man man Ben Meraki ski or
whatever the [ __ ] your name is Joey
loves you [ __ ] [ __ ] I'm
always good like like I you know I came
back from the other one you said the
mike vehicle yeah I always believed that
even before I got locked up God does
something wrong he does his time he
comes out he gets a benefit out my eyes
who he [ __ ] up again I was wrong
you don't angry I've always been one of
those I think that's point I got locked
up and I you know and I thought when I
got in trouble I thought about running I
thought a lot of things and I thought
about what I believed I was saying you
know what I'd do my [ __ ] time I come
out who the [ __ ] the house I can
always sell mm-hmm I don't know if I
could [ __ ] do this that like low we
sell you know and you'll figure it out I
figured it out but it wasn't I kidnapped
somebody you know I was a thief that
type of stuff there was no more but one
time I got I kind of huge twice one time
was a forced acute it really wasn't
accused of you really look at it but one
time I got accused of [ __ ] sexual
[ __ ]
and it killed me and the people wouldn't
tell me that I got accused when was this
it had to be 20 years ago 25 years ago I
was doing Carly and that was that my
friend you know Chrissy fish mm-hmm and
[ __ ] his brother God rest his soul I
can't [ __ ] think of his name Jesus
Christ anyway you know he was married to
this check he was about 30 but he was
married to a chick that was like 50 and
they were both high-rolling junkies you
know I was the plumber I used to hang
out with Jesus Christ I used to take me
and stinky into the city and he'd get
heroin and we get pills a meal you can
aim your bonehead
I love the bonehead so bonehead was
married to an older chick and I was at
that parents house I was tight with
Bonin parents I grew up a Bolton's
parents I've been hanging out with
bonehead society this is 97 I did time I
went back you know I was brothers with
all three kids I was always one of those
guys I just didn't hang out with Josh
right with Josh I know with Jonathan I
know we're [ __ ] the other [ __ ] one
Gary Ellen so you hang out with
different I hung out with all three
brothers that you're the one brother and
me got pills together and giggled the
other brother and me the least one that
I liked
he always had good coke and I always
know how to dump jewelry out of this
[ __ ] and the other brother I grew up
with so they know everything about me
and I'm in the pool in this and it's
boneheads me boneheads are in the pool
Chris fresh his son and bonehead
stepdaughter mm-hmm and stepson or maybe
the steps home wasn't tampered the
stepdaughter was there you know we're
all in there you know when you pick up
the kids throat like he throw them to
somebody else yeah like they threw her
at me she must have been like 14 or 15
and I grabbed her under her armpits I
threw her back
I collected that like two or three times
good to go we got out of the pool we ate
we sat around and that's it two days
later I thought I left I come back nine
months later do Rascals or something
and again I didn't hear nothing again
but I hadn't heard from bald head
bald-headed stopped calling he was in
Vegas at the time mmm and then one day
Chris told me if Brian told me to say
this to you he goes you know how much I
believed this much
she says I've gotten up and because bond
had lived with them with the two kids
downstairs for a few years so they had
caused a little time for problems these
kids so he goes when you left that time
she said you touched her and I was like
who were you talking about
and he goes to curl they go first off
come on no I was before that eight guys
yeah it was that's what I said yeah
that's the first thing I said I hope she
didn't say that the stepfather was right
in the pool and somebody would have seen
something yeah but I was also scared of
I guess I always thought that if I
stayed and bowled with my wife would say
something about the kid something would
have gone wrong that way and then when I
was an open mic I got bent and the
comedy works one time because the chick
jumped on me and when I grabbed her I
grabbed her ass but it wasn't like I
grabbed and squeezed them that's where
my hands landed I was tight with the
girl week later I get banned for life
but now I'm back at the Cali was because
there was nothing it really was my
remember when you were paying yeah it
was really nothing so I've never been
like a deviant like that yeah you bump
into freaks and you know what Jason
juice you know that they're running
other times I need to drink that juice
and place your lucky number you ever go
to a supermarket and you gotta wait for
20 minutes you pull eight and it's your
lucky number it's number eight oh my god
I remember I just feel I can't I
I listen to view did something to me and
I got the proof whatever yeah but for me
to come out now
go hey 32 years ago you did this listen
to me a favor go [ __ ] yourself and if I
did do it listen I apologize and I'm
sorry that was a long and things happen
what are you gonna do that dude okay so
that dude who the dude who touched the
fourteen-year-old or whatever the [ __ ]
happened say he touched a 14 year old 30
years ago then nothing
oh so say say it dude John who I didn't
know anything about this would sound
like politics so I saw the name on CNN
the sexual misconduct yeah it was yeah
you know and look I try not to watch the
news either because who the [ __ ] knows
what but the accusation is that when he
was third in his 30s he dated teenagers
and then in particular one girl was 14 I
guess but there's like did you see that
he signed her yearbook
no he signed her as a girl that's not
good yeah and he was like I don't know
where and they were a hill [ __ ]
you said the yearbook they said he would
go like walking around malls to like
yeah but he was bored that's what he
said he was doing but there's and
there's a couple like articles that just
say his town people in his town was just
well known that he dated teenagers now
what if you asked somebody to eat their
[ __ ] is that sexual is common with him
you say so let me ask you a question
you're looking really good to me what if
whatever you let me lick that monkey no
I dunno what I think it is I think it is
I think one of the funniest things I've
ever heard anyone say on stage was you
and it might be considered at this in
today's day and age maybe sexual
misconduct we were at the [ __ ] haha
cafe and there were maybe
seven people there eight but two of them
were two Asian girls in the front
ah poor girls and you get on stage and
your fist is just pumping just pop it
and you're like you do like tea jokes
and he go oh hey Sheena and there you go
look at you - mm-hmm you make me want to
go home and pull a karate kid with
myself
you're like I would eat your [ __ ] with
chopsticks you went in a chopstick roll
and I was like that's like the for his
yeah they were howling laughing by the
way well you couldn't do that right now
the girls yeah no listen people go to a
comedy show yeah you got to listen if
you go to a comedy show and you're
showing excessive cleavage excessive
there's cleavage that is appropriate
there's a little over appropriate which
you look at and go that's a pretty dress
the science but then there's cleavage
where it's to the line of the diario de
whatever the [ __ ] areola it's like it's
like [ __ ] - Jeannie what do you call
it of Ray Liotta aralia so you're
sitting in the front row
you and your girlfriend you both have
the same blouse on yeah it's like one of
us has a miniskirt and you got heels and
the miniskirt barely covers your [ __ ]
okay if you address them they're not
gonna get mad at you that's the reason
why they got dolled up but at the same
time if you don't address it they might
get a little pissed off at you during
picture time they'll come up here and
say I sat in the front row and you
didn't say nothing about me one time
it's so [ __ ] weird if someone is
wearing a skirt would that doesn't cover
their [ __ ] I'm gonna go ahead and
assume that they want me to look at that
that is an on purpose thing like you
don't leave your your [ __ ] out unless
you want someone to look at it but from
the same tone that's why I attacked
shayla's if there's two cheetahs up in
the front row and then two girls that
just came off the boat in Japan they got
the glasses on they did every glasses no
no no they weren't the one girl was like
Philippine and the one girl was Mexican
with Chinese eyes so that's why I was
talking remember that night I remember
now they weren't on the couch in the
front yeah and they had a guy behind him
and they were both really hot it's 11
o'clock at night dude they were howling
like cuz you know what's on your mind
I'm telling you what's on your mind
these are two beautiful girls that work
hard all week why are they ass and 11
o'clock at night on Lancashire there's
only one reason why and none of you
people in this room is saying it I know
what they're both here for because but
because I'm 50 I have not a chance with
these girls even with a pound the blow a
half a million dollars these girls
wouldn't give it up they're looking for
a hot young guy to come in drink them up
and you know what these two girls are
probably too old one year if you played
your cards right if you write them over
to your house to press the button
whatever they wanna do I love opera you
do well I got a library out previewing I
[ __ ] but you're gonna go home and while
they're pissing you're gonna google
opera mmm and you're gonna take a quick
lesson on Pavarotti real quick is born
in Milano and 16 turn out in the opera
station and turn of the opera station
and next thing you know they start
kissing each other you never know you
never know but they're not waiting for a
[ __ ] chubby fat [ __ ] with 50 years
old and away for that so you get away
with [ __ ] and stay yeah you know you I'm
gonna keep saying what I'm saying but
you all you have to keep saying what
you're saying yeah how are you saying
how you believe every time I've tried to
go away from that I backfire I've turned
it into a certain right now after 30
years I've been doing this all my life
I've been person and talking the way
I've been talking all my life yeah and
the people and what they talked away
because I analyst it and guess what then
I rate list they're not racist you know
there are anything but they say crazy
[ __ ] [ __ ] - yeah but that's a thing
like you you should be able to say crazy
[ __ ] that's that's not like you know you
shouldn't yes you should be able to
crazy crazy [ __ ] if you could back it
with your character and with your belief
in what you say but then you won't you
ever see a comic that goes upstairs goes
onstage and just beat that's that's come
I use you is this example every time I
talk to people about this when they talk
about being dirty onstage and I say it
doesn't matter how dirty you are it
matters where it comes from like you're
dirty on stage but it's your complete
truth and because it's your complete
truth sure I'm assuming you've offended
some people before but because it's your
complete truth people accept it but you
can tell when people get on stage and
are being dirty just to be dirty and
then it comes across so it's like the
fakes then yeah
comes across the dirty water so it's
phase of the fake stanhope oh no only
ones down oh my god fake stanhope yeah
and they're everywhere - everywhere -
everywhere especially like in clicky
towns they leave your face - hello
dude you know it took me a long time to
figure out what I did on stage and I
would tell you if I'm being honest it
just happened in the last three or four
years three years maybe
now you've been doing comedies as I know
you 23 years yeah but I'm telling you
right now to get somewhere with it by
this yeah yeah yeah 22 years you get to
this certain you know but but but I
figured out okay so I think I've always
done it but I just figured out what it
was
so I I might as well tell people when I
get on stage and I hope you didn't come
here to learn anything tonight because
that's not what my show is people like
one of my my favorite thing people say
to me is you're not angry up there like
you're not mad you don't seem like a
pissed-off comic my shows are kind of
fun like that's what I do that's kind of
what my Energy's always been but I used
to fight it and try to be like oh I need
to be a little darker here or be I just
that's not my thing
and so my shows have turned into it's
like a it's a it's just I want people to
the stories are stupid man there's
stupid stories about my kids or about me
or about you know taking mushrooms that
are old at Coachella last year whatever
they did the story is passing out on
Ventura Boulevard a couple months ago
whatever where's the oxygen tank yeah
right where is it
it's back at the house we'll use it oh
no my grades are not so good but I'm
just saying like you Jews always got
they always then you get the check and
that's it yeah always use keep the floor
you gotta keep the thing I get the hand
one no no you gotta keep the tube and
walk with it and then put the neck brace
on for [ __ ] that's Jewish jewelry
it's getting close to Hanukkah you got a
bust of that yeah I made someone super
nervous when I took that [ __ ] hand
one out on the plane
because he who I hated but it was like I
needed a quick little hit and then guys
looked to me I was like bits
it's okay nothing's about to go down 22
years you've been doing yeah yeah yeah
at some point listen but you know the
point where you raise levels instantly
yeah there's a point where I went to
jiu-jitsu last weekend this button this
black belt came it
my god this bottle belt was doing [ __ ]
he had everything Josh wolf this guy's a
cop of whether God yeah that could jump
over you he was jumping from side to
side hooking homes golf four legs this
black dog just sat there like it was
another day at the office
I never saw anything like that this guy
said he had him inside control and you
know how this guy was getting out we out
with his arms just school he kept
spinning the guy and he finally caught
his leg and flipped him back and then
the guy came at him again he just kept
him there for four minutes and finally
the professors at time and I looked at
the brown that the brown bat was all
[ __ ] up and the button I'll just fix
it he a little bit because he knows
exactly what you yeah what you're gonna
do I feel for the first time as a comic
I feel very
not clunky anymore I found my direction
Jesus Christ we poked it back to Seattle
yeah we thought we had the world by the
balls in 96 no we were just getting
started we were just learning about the
wrench yeah you know and I wish I had
trusted my instinct if I was gonna say
anything uncommon I wish I had trusted
my instinct about what I did well
earlier but you always you know when
you're young you most of us
I'm assuming some people don't but most
people pattern themselves after a comic
like how many people would tells cadence
have you heard come out of New York
oh right right so you pattern yourself
after somebody and at some point if you
when you if you take that next step you
start to find your voice and I fought
mine for a long time I really did just
because I knew what type of comedy I
appreciated that I would go watch and
what I do well isn't necessarily what I
would go watch that makes sense but
that's not that's not what so so I kept
trying fighting it towards what I wanted
to what I wanted to be what I watched on
stage what I liked and I had to modify
that a little bit well we have to we all
cut the fat that that's the experience
yeah the experience comes and just get
it
it's so weird when I talk to young
comics and just well for your tell you
know you're my witness
there was a time here I got on stage
everything we I didn't care what you
were doing I really didn't give a [ __ ]
yeah my brother I love you but haven't
come to see graduate from IOU or [ __ ]
ImprovOlympic
so I'm not gonna show I didn't show
anything those days the first thing you
have to do is a set then you do
something I took it back to school then
when you got sick and you tried to go
out at 3:15 mm-hmm where you going going
to play you were sick no no but I feel
bad
you will sit you're gonna make sure that
nothing happens that's the way I always
took Connolly back that because then I
was miserable I was starving what the
[ __ ] was either doing he said who the
[ __ ] was I to do anything I wasn't even
in the game are you gonna get in the
game if you're at somebody's party
celebrate and jumbled up and down
there's a coffee shed you learn more at
that coffee shop on that Sunday night
which one
okay there was a coffee shop and when
you when you come off about him
Boulevard the first place you ever took
me through you took me to a coffee shop
in the Saturn yeah well you pulled up to
Barham but instead of making a right
like you're going into Burbank you made
a left and you went straight in that
building there that's in our production
building yeah was run by a friend of
yours so there was a script place yeah
where you went in then you could pull
scripts and read old scripts they tried
it and just this old coffee yeah yeah
open mic yeah but then you also took me
to a place in the deep part of Melrose
over the first coffee shops and one of
maybe only coffee shops I went there
wasn't you on a Sunday they me you and
Gavin went to a Sunday night off of
Melrose office Melrose yeah I [ __ ]
like that just some [ __ ] friendly
yours who booked the coffee showers
something like that we also did the bar
where we all bombed and in the heart of
Hollywood Bowl shares the black dude
with dreads AJ Jamal and [ __ ] [ __ ]
our zoo man and zoomin
Cory and the black dude from how to pick
up a single chick Oh Pierre yeah yeah
appears back in town
yeah yeah what's he doing bald ah he
shaved his head yeah I don't know I
don't know what I saw him down at the
store and then also saw the little guy
back
Hensley judge really you know what
happened to AJ Jamal he didn't movies
and he writes and he pops up in time to
time I think he's B does the casino
thing Manny alright Tommy laughs well
the hardest guys I ever had a follow the
mother one of the guys that when I got a
spot the comedy store I would hate to
say who's in front of me and they said
hey Jim I love dumb a rat right think of
canceling yeah agent Amal was tough
tough and down still you know I love
watching down so what I was little at
the Laugh Factory a monthly show I go
down there for him I got on there to sit
and watch him and see how he pushes
people's buttons that's 35 years ago
master because if I'm doing comedy 27
years I saw him on HBO when I was not
don't come yeah so that's a complete
different [ __ ] level of company but he
does it so masterfully yeah he [ __ ]
is that's what you are right now I'm
burnt out I'm Lily Bertha but I'll tell
you something it's a bad time to be
burnt up mmm because I'm doing well on
stage hmm for the first year like I got
that I finally figured out the formula
the formula to get like to prepare for a
special yeah it's the same thing as a
fight if I don't do the special right
it's because I don't make wait this last
special I didn't train correctly for it
to be honest I never trained for
anything the special may lead to the
seed the the first one was on the drive
down today and then and I think it's one
of the best things I ever did it's what
do you mean I tried to drive down to
Brea we discussed doing a CD and he
rented the thing
for 35 bucks and we cleaned that up and
put it on iTunes you did the set and
Brad yeah and I still think to this day
one's one take one set no I'm not it's
one of my best sets ever in my mind now
I doing crazy sets like that and switch
it up yeah talking a little bit now the
story I didn't know you that much at
that point I mean do you remember how
much of it was like what you were doing
at that point or was that just off the
cuff that night it was it was poised the
holiday so I had 15 right holidays I had
20 that I came up with and tortilla that
I was working on and I just thought
happened to fit there's some nice would
just you have to have a tape recorder
because you never know and that was Wow
the other things I take the garbage
anything else I'd tape those garbage and
the see so special I read it like a
[ __ ] five but I learned from it and I
learned that by the time I got to the
special I was birthed up I listened to
other people it's just like training for
a [ __ ] fight and I'd rather do it
here first for three or four weeks yeah
and then do two solid weeks and trim off
the fat or maybe do four out of five
that's how to do it four out of five
white knights know four out of five
weeks so you trim the fat off for about
three we see it flappers the Comedy
Store The Laugh Factory in the improv
it's a journey it's not gonna be easy
wait and you're gonna dance how I would
do it tell what to do it but you you
couldn't do an hour at all those places
know so let's say you come to me and go
Joey want you to shoot a special
February first today November whatever I
bang out brand I'd bang out the store
tomorrow night I bang out [ __ ] Irvine
and I start from scratch
first battleground the Sacramento I
tested up there bettin Brown will they
do 45 minutes in 30 I would have really
taken it too deep
yeah the underwater I don't want them to
come up you talk about this one here
yeah if I get this one here so I would
probably do that from the heavier
surgery so once I recovered that whole
weekend here surgery will shut down the
podcast and then probably just Khalil we
gonna tape some ahead of time no no I
like dome in the day I want the full
pitar that [ __ ] about let's make believe
it's next Friday the 28th and then they
shoot the president hey you me are
talking about baseball [ __ ] you Dupre
tapes so uh what we coming yeah I would
do it that way I would do a month here
and then two weeks on the road take a
week off two more weeks on the roof
you're doing a half an hour on the road
don't 45 on the road but I'm gonna work
for 45 and 30 for a special do you
follow me I'll get trying to get 45
minutes of material in 30 so you don't
breathe I'm gonna come out there jump
I'm gonna jog I'm gonna get my endurance
up I'm gonna go to doctor hey me to
clean my lungs out that's why my ones
have been wheezing cuz I haven't done to
see doc baby that's my plan when is that
special when do you think you'll have it
done well this I don't know I don't know
if I would I'm just assuming but now I
know how to do it correctly it's just
like a fight you have to peak with the
special
so if you did two weeks on the road two
weeks on and then you took a week off
needed two more weeks five more shows
ten shows and now you shut that
specialist following Saturday night and
then you work flappers and the Ice House
that Wednesday you'll be ready and then
that Friday when you get in that local
town we'll go to an open mic somewhere
and tell them you want to do ten minutes
like Chicago has a thousand open mics
yeah go do an open mic do twenty-five
minutes and you're ready to shoot a
special I you don't want to over burn
no and you don't want to under prepare
ci but I would rather be under than over
so for me this time when I shot this one
I went a little I always go just a
little bit under because I like to
because when I go over I I think it gets
to memorized for me well that's what
happens because like this time here I
got caught up in the jokes you cannot
get caught up in the jokes you have to
own the jokes but lose them and
improvise a little bit
it's like when you learn it on bar I
could teach you an arm bar hand you them
and landed on book you're not gonna get
it because you gotta trick me right you
gotta figure out a way now how to trick
me so hello I'm stays there so all I
gotta do is grab it and spin and now
that leg comes over good night Irene but
if I'm gonna wrestle with you on two
arms yeah it's gonna and I'm pushing off
your heel it's what you see it coming
it's not the armbar it's the trick going
into the armbar it's how I'm gonna get
that arm to stay there you know yeah
it's doing comedy different when you're
shooting versus when you're at a club
like I imagine if you've seen them you
camera yeah you've been there for
everything how do you do you never see
me do anything better than the Icehouse
those working out with uncle Joey's now
that's great you're free you just free
there's something about with that tell
the audience that listen this is a
roller coaster I was even thinking about
doing a work and I want uncle Joey talk
yeah just going to Teddy Gray's listen
15 bucks at the door
don't worry about nothing yeah how're
you here tonight there's a little ease
on the table and we're gonna fold
forward here some of my best oh that's
the funniest [ __ ] in the world some of
my best shows are late shows that don't
sell that well because they eat there
it's Chris it's the loosest it's the
loosest loose and we've already done a
set yeah we've already done a set so
we've already been at bat yeah now the
second show you're already you're
already loose so me I gotta tell you
something this is my problem lately
my big problem lately is listen
traditionally the first show does not
like Joey Diaz traditionally in the
early shaft the early show these people
walk in because a friend told him go see
this guy when they get there I opens up
with some obscure and the battleship
sinks from there
so I've learned to energize them and
enjoy those sets where even a dental tip
the material is funny just my actions
and my energy I'm off a little bit and
they'll go wow that was something
different well you know what I learned
last year I know if I told you this but
I used to I used to move around a lot on
stage a lot and then last like dizzy you
dizzy people yeah people does the into
ten minutes yeah it was to my butt last
year and last year yeah last year in the
year before I really did basically every
set with the mic in the stand and that
was it that's it a little touch for
microphone with the [ __ ] stand now
now I'm I don't move nearly as much now
I'll take it out every now and then but
I'm pretty still but it it took just
trying to get out of my comfort zone a
little bit to realize all that was okay
this all comes from experience if you're
a young comic you could sit there and
trick yourself because you're going for
the quickest route right now
to get somewhere I'm telling you about
the best route to get somewhere which is
time and longevity yeah a lot here too
soon you're not gonna have the legs to
do what you want to do and if you want
to come out here and travel you have my
wish also you know you're my blessing
also you're going for it but I'd rather
you do the struggling in your hometown
and come out here when you 135 and
you're throwing [ __ ] heat the
struggle is too hard here do you would
you have rather stayed in Seattle I have
grew Seattle yes all right
I have grossie a low and that was that
that was I did two three years there and
I had already outgrown it beside my
criminal problems I could tell that I
outgrew it because the guys that were
supposed to UM motivate me weren't
motivating me no I was motivated by the
guys in my class yeah the guys that were
ahead of me in the Seattle not coming
back and going oh my god you got to see
what's going on it was until I met a guy
by the name of
in Seattle the guy that I had to follow
that night and died that he was in that
movie the burbs with Tom Hanks I was
gonna say boy Dunkleman that boy loved
me the guy had to follow he came at
either that movie with Tom Hanks and the
dunk Rick Rick Rick Rick to come and do
commit that guy was the first guy that
really opened my eyes until that's right
he kind of took you under his wing when
I became friends with yeah a little
buddy I when I got off you waited for me
but you you you got in touch with him
down here still - yes that touch to him
and I did everything he told me - oh
that it when I would call him upset he
would tell me not to be upset
this is but do you plan on staying here
yeah then that's just you're not gonna
hit the first two weeks not anymore
it's not the seventies here you know
it's not the 70s here where they put
y'all welcome back collars in action or
the way I didn't get that dead now I
understand it but it's a tough sell
young comics yeah it's a very tough sell
to young comics to listen you get
sponsors on a Friday then you get in
spots at the improv keep your mouth shut
go to your spots right and keep doing
this [ __ ] it yourselfer commercial age
get ready go on auditions the proper way
I want the audition site I mean yeah
do I want to do it every [ __ ] today
you like it not but I tell you why not
dishes good you see people you see
people you haven't seen oh yeah because
you [ __ ] you think you guys who go out
for what you go out for are probably the
same it's the same group of dudes right
but it's funny when I first got here I
went out against Frank Stallone show you
about a Fuko it was intimidating this
[ __ ] when I first got out here I've
never going to an audition and seen the
guy that they froze and Goodfellas in
the audition I just [ __ ] my baby going
after him I'm like why am I here he got
his Frankie Carbone
yeah he got frozen in Goodfellas you
know you don't is to follow those guys
yeah but I was also 32 33 then today I
went into a room and the most notable
guy in there you don't know late
sons of anarchy the guy whose daughter
kicked over Jack's Towers when they went
to his house and he invited him in he
was really good right I get that well I
owe you for the bike my guys like
nothing was square and he paid for his
mortgage that dude was there I hadn't
seen him in 10 years and it's funny cuz
he sat right next to me cuz how you
doing I know you were great in the sun's
I am I do I know the guys name I
I wouldn't know if I told you but it was
it's the same group there was another
guy there that I go up against for all
mobster plumber yeah Rose Lee goes it's
good to see ya can I go how is it been
you know we went outside we all walked
we were on wash what oh yeah which I
want to get a slice of pizza for Lee and
I changed my mind
down on the corner that's where they say
is the best pizzas good that's good
pizza yeah that guy old one up in
Hollywood that was very good but he sold
it no
but when I was there walk down the
stairs even though it was trafficking
the whole family I like to enjoy this
and that I can be a little picky and
shoot like this one this morning when I
woke up I'm like and and then all of
this but I can't turn them down because
they're coming and when they do you want
to keep coming you guys show up please
you didn't want excuse um time that we
have a 6 o'clock for you in Santa Monica
I don't know what happened tonight boy
the car blew up a house how many
appointments have you cancelled in Santa
Monica a million I just don't set them
when they go I say where's your office
they say Santa Monica where where else
can we meet where else can we meet they
were I don't I thought you went through
hell because four people home don't
understand is these pitch meetings
nobody went to more pitch meetings in
Josh warm and you know that nobody sees
you till 4:30 everybody wants to see
your foot and then you get the court
3:30 yet they can't see you so far and
you're on Santa Monica and the 5th
Street and the MTV building yeah because
you know when you make when you and the
best is when you go upstairs there's a
10-minute pitch or 15-minute [ __ ] thing
well thank you for coming well questions
they don't well thanks thanks for coming
in that was great
and you get in that car and you make the
left on Olympic the right a little input
it's just a line and the line the line
the light changes three times and you
move 2 inches worked an Olympic for 2
years
don't bet understands it right from
wherever that like to get from even
Bundy that's why it works
in Olympic to the 405 can take like [ __ ]
it's bananas right it like especially
like we had nights where we he would
have shows at the Ice House on Wednesday
nights and I the show would be like 8:30
9:00 o'clock I would leave at 6:30 and
just make it it's 20 miles you were
talking earlier about how there's people
who you don't like you lose track of in
LA yeah what about your friends who just
like live in Culver City no I'm never
gonna see you I'm sorry yeah my my
brother
lives in Santa Monica your brother my
brother lives in Santa Monica
but he's always like hey you won't come
down here I'm like do you want to come
up here because it neither one of us
while I get on the [ __ ] 405 but but
it's just gets cuz la so spread out
right there's no real public
transportation and everything takes like
[ __ ] 45 minutes to get that's why you
know I used to keep I used to keep food
in my car how much food well okay so I
used to work when I worked on staff at
Chelsea the first place was basically
Olympic in bundi right yeah I think was
across the street from where I worked
yeah yeah you work through the Hulu
Office right yeah the right there yeah
yeah so you know yeah that could take a
little while so I would put some I
always pack food in the morning no put
it in it keep it in there because I'm no
dummy you didn't never last like an hour
and a half in the car I never packed
food in the car I put [ __ ] snacks
right in the middle are you kidding I
get too into the snacks that crash oh
you're only doing two miles an hour so
you smoke a little weed I mean you had
your little show that [ __ ] is gonna
come out pretty soon as that you felt up
that teddies man audition them for the
cowboy girl as a matter of fact ah the
one time I had somebody in my office
that I needed to talk to because
somebody in my office made a call to get
somebody fired pretended to be somebody
else
they made a call to a company that I had
hired to get somebody that company had
sent over fired because she didn't like
that person and we had to figure out who
it was
so when I brought one of the women into
the office I made sure that there was
somebody else in the office because I
hadn't even thought of it and then the
showrunner was like you know you're
gonna have somebody in that meeting with
you I said why and she was like if if
you ever intend up having to fire her
she can say whatever she wants about
what happened in that office you gonna
have our
yeah hi everyone hi I didn't even think
about it either because obviously I
wasn't that wasn't my intention but she
was like no you can't you can't be in
there by yourself because if we do have
to end up firing her somebody has to
have been in that office with you Matt
it would have never crossed my mind
you know I just weird we're we're gone
it's just weird where we're going with
this it's just really weird and like I
said I don't mind we all [ __ ] up and
make mistakes but don't don't don't make
[ __ ] fire weather ain't one you know
they'll make a beef where they're really
and that's it that's a scary thing like
it's making women safer and the
workplace what's it like I'm not in the
position to hire anybody but as a man it
would be a little scarier to hire the
hot receptors in this er do someone like
that don't you think you just have to
you I think right now you have to just
be extra diligent that you know how
would I take that truck take pictures
and show what people have to shows I'm
thinking I just hugging the guy and even
that's gonna stop and just stand there
like [ __ ] like every tantrics yeah
hand in your pocket that's it
cuz it's getting bad out there then got
time for this [ __ ] next couple weeks
this weekend I'm in Kansas City
Oh were you born back to the wig I'm not
all right
I told you did I ever tell you what he
said to me this was imagine we heat
yours uh hey he pulled me into his
office one day you'll say this is so
funny we're gonna talk about the
Pharaohs hey you [ __ ] teenagers you know
what what do you [ __ ] teenagers think I
know any us okay that was it oh there it
is oh yeah so um I made at the KC improv
this weekend I think it's the senator
where the son of my love tell him I'll
be there we had a misunderstanding last
time oh well because I know where he's
going after that where you do use the
I'm taking most of December off for you
and but I do that podcast with Freddie
Prinze jr. called prints in the wall oh
[ __ ] that's right he's like a shout out
it should we say I was going on with you
mom was leaving him up I'm very proud of
you
he hooked mom up usually put it at being
be like some [ __ ] make the death
begin
don't worry until they they will Buster
and then give her a cosby pill there's
something you were gonna [ __ ] you we
didn't that your mom says they got a
raid over at the Picasso they took care
of them well that's my mom like the
hotel it's a good camera whether it's
decent before that steakhouse at all
downstairs no no the sushi place does
have you know why don't we we didn't go
there we went to a different one
Riverside Riverside oh yeah yeah yeah
next to or like all that stuff there dr.
Haney was up to corner my friends stayed
there one I mean there are options up
here so there's a [ __ ] that
Sportsman's Lodge
that's know I heard that's not good no
hookers no no in the middle of night
come on people yelling yeah bro and then
like the nice one
like the Holiday Inn down the corner is
what 280 and I cross the street from the
Denny's and the backyard is a Ford
dealership there are no nice hotels in
the valley
no this Burbank has one you gotta make a
right but then that's 15 20 minutes away
I like having my
I said light man that's down whatever
Street it's biker it's across the street
from popeyes chicken there I suppose the
best hotels in the valley that one there
that's what gangsters stay that's for
[ __ ] in George Mazda var stay and UFC
fighters they put them over there when
they do the Fox Broadway
yeah that's where I know a guy that owns
a company and stays there anyway go to
Josh wolf dotnet with his comedian Josh
off that couch comedian Josh wolf
dot-com and get you all your Josh wolf
rent info as far as the flying Jew he's
always looking good he's going into
Hanukkah season ready to [ __ ] go but
without further ado let me explain
something that I've really and I've
heard great things about him if you need
great talent for your business but
you're short on time you just you just
have to get lost in the huge stack of
resumes to find your perfect eye you
just need to write tools
what if hiring could be easier more
streamlined and less time-consuming so
even when you're busy you could still be
smart about the way you hire if you're
hiring you know that quality hires keep
your business moving forward correct
yeah but you also know it can take a lot
of time to find the right candidate you
don't want to post your job to find the
right candidate you know how hard it is
to find the right candidate it's tough
as hell out there especially when
there's so many candidates available to
you but with zip recruiter you can post
your job to over 100 of the web's
leading job boards with just one click
so you can rest easy knowing your job is
being seen by the right candidates then
zip recruiter puts it smart matching
technology to work actively notifying
qualified candidates about your job
within minutes of postings you can
receive the best possible matches
quickly that's why is it recruiters
different unlike the other hiring sites
zip recruiter does not depend on the
right candidates finding you it finds
them you can even get a head start of
the interview process by adding
screening questions to your job post to
identify the most qualified candidates
who you not to waste time
strolling through a stack of resumes to
find the perfect fit no wonder 80% of
employers who post on zip recruited get
quality candidates through the site in
just one day
that's why zip recruiter is the smartest
way to hire let me tell you what I'm
gonna do for you cuz your uncle Joey
likes you the holidays are coming the
new year is coming
you want to get rid of that dead wood in
your office is what you're gonna do
gonna zip recruiter all right now it's
been used by growing businesses of all
sizes and industry so I don't care if
you're a shoe store whatever you do zip
recruiter I'll hook you up and right now
listeners can post jobs on zip recruit
are you ready free free free that's
right free just going to zip recruiter
slash shirts eh you are CH that zip
recruiter slash Church one more time
we're gonna give it to you for free
zip recruit in a slash Church listen zip
recruiter is the best way to go when
you're looking for a qualified candidate
now it's a new year you've been single
for ten months you know you don't know
what's going on with yourself I mean you
got a nice job you know a nice car you
got a nice cat you got everything to
catch a girl you got that tattoo I mean
you've done it all have you ever
considered your [ __ ] stinky ass on
your nutsack do you look at women's
faces when they go down on you you see
that that onion is [ __ ] protruding
then those hands you you see that little
Filipino eyebrows raising up you know
why is your ass stinks and it carries
over into your nutsack by your helmet
and surrounds your helmet it's right
there in that area with the jeans
that's why hello Toshi comm is the way
to go I mean listen Thanksgiving is a
time to express your gratitude and
recollect on what you're truly grateful
for it's also time when you invite your
family members those [ __ ] savages
into your home to eat up all your turkey
and then they go in your bathroom they
blow it up with that post-meal shits
this year make sure when your family
shits in your house they leave with a
clean [ __ ] [ __ ] you must start in
life you know saying
you get a tooshie birthday for $69 with
a risk-free 90 day trial 90 day trial
listen don't have grandma leave with
that [ __ ] stink bucket of an [ __ ]
with gravy but give until she hear I'm
saying why are you gonna make a why put
that flimsy toilet paper I'll [ __ ]
your roller fingers gonna bust through
the paper then she's gonna have a [ __ ]
on her fingernails try to give you a
corn on the cob [ __ ] that [ __ ]
pushy to the rescue [ __ ] so she will
wash away all those mash potatoes with a
gentle stream of water straight to your
little muffler giving it the best clean
you've ever had I mean listen people
want to leave the leftovers but they're
not hanging their [ __ ] you're fine
no no dingleberries when you got to she
make sure you're ready for the holiday
bum-rush with tushy stop wiping with
that [ __ ] nasty toilet paper your
finger always breaks through it and now
you got back tearing your fingernail and
you want to hang out with your friends
and eat fruit and [ __ ] [ __ ] that [ __ ]
get the douchey but day but days are
back you filthy animals hello [ __ ] calm
right now and use the code church for
10% off your honor the end of your
stinky [ __ ] ends now let me tell you
something you know those people you look
at and you look at you go you know what
I can't pick a winner at the track well
I'll tell you what I bet his [ __ ]
snakes like ten dead [ __ ] cabbages
give him a big day for Christmas it's
$69 for the 60 day guarantee if Lee
still has his and I still have mine what
does that tell you about the quality
within within the stink all the weight
we would have busted by now the [ __ ]
tushy has still there holding on don't
[ __ ] up go to hell old pushy calm and
use code Church for 10% off your order
I want to thank Felice I add I want to
thank Josh wolf and I want to take the
church family there having our [ __ ]
back all right I'll see you
[ __ ] tomorrow even if you don't
have tickets I need you outside with
signs sticks bazookas machine guns we
gotta show Netflix who the [ __ ]
running things you understand me I'll
see you Wednesday night or Thursday stay
black have a great weekend Josh both one
more time and my main man Lisa an aka
the original Christ killer
[Music]